a Virginia school has temporarily banned
two classic books to Kill a Mockingbird
by Harper Lee and Huckleberry Finn by
Mark Twain because a parent said that
her high school-aged son was negatively
impacted by the racial slurs contained
in the books the parent whose son is
biracial said that her concerns are
quote not even just a black and white
thing saying I keep hearing this is a
classic this is a classic I understand
this is a literature classic but at some
point I feel that children will not or
do not truly get the classic part the
literature part which I'm not disputing
this is great literature but there are
so many racial slurs in there and
defensive wording that you can't get
past that and she said that her son was
reading Huckleberry Finn for a high
school assignment and couldn't get past
a certain page because the n-word
appeared seven times in it racial slurs
appear 219 times in Huckleberry Finn and
48 times in To Kill a Mockingbird as a
result Accomack County Public Schools
Superintendent Chris Holland said that
the district has temporarily suspended
the books and appointed a committee to
recommend whether the book should remain
in the curriculum and in high school
libraries I think most in our audience
know what my thought is on this this is
absolutely terrible I recall reading
books in school that contained the
n-word and other racial slurs certainly
in fourth grade when I was 9 to 10 years
old but maybe even earlier we're talking
about a high school here there was never
a question about whether these words
were ok to say there was never a
question about the difference between
when the books were taking place and
when we were reading it and you might
say well David you're not black so you
heard the n-word and you weren't
affected by it because it wasn't about
your group when studying World War 2 and
the Holocaust in many classes there was
no shortage of readings that contained
horrible slurs and statements about Jews
a group that I am a part of and it was
notable to say at the time we said yet
that do we understand what this is we
aren't going to
cancel these readings because that would
be a disservice to the students we're
going to talk about the fact that these
are horrible things to say and banning
books doesn't work out well neither just
burning them by the way I am completely
against this decision Pat yeah and it's
also important to point out that the
themes of these books are against racism
against slavery yeah and the characters
use the n-word and other racial slurs in
order to elicit a certain response
against them that's the whole point and
this mother saying that the the books
accepts that language just isn't true I
absolutely agree with you and I want to
mention something else in particular in
this particular case you've got a lot of
right-wingers saying oh this is
left-wing trigger warnings safe space
politically correct nonsense and this is
a problem of the left don't forget that
when the right wants to ban books
because they go against conservative
ideology because they don't include God
and discussions of science or because of
descriptions of sexual acts or being
used for sexual education purposes and
they don't allow it aligned with
religious conservatism the right does
the same thing saying no no no my kids
can't handle this ban these books this
is just another version of it and this
time Pat it's the right-wingers saying
it's the lefties who are wrong but the
right is also very much involved
involved in the banning of material they
don't want often for so-called religious
reasons yeah and then they go around
saying that they're never against any
sections on free speech and censorship
and they're not at for space safe spaces
all the stuff it's absolutely bogus it's
a double standard but I am completely
against this I think that those books
absolutely need to be and we're talking
about high school this was something
that in my fourth grade class we were
reading not these specific books but
books with this equivalent level of
racial slurs and and profanity and we're
talking about high school students here